皆さん
性という言葉を聞いてどんなことを思い浮かべますか
おしぼりの話ですよ
まあ一般的にはひまわり出るのか例えば gs とかまあそういったことがパッと
思い浮かぶんじゃないかなと思います
ただそういった野菜がそれぐらいの大きなでどんな形をしていて今どこにいて
どうやったかになっているのかというところまで詳しく知って言ってはあまりないん
じゃないかなと
こんな下等なことをしゃべって私に県府中はこんな好きじゃないん
大学に入るまでは宇宙のことを全く考えたことなかったのかねん
にもかかわらず私は今超小型得ている
異論小さい明日をつくる
円卓には木に触れません
蹴ったことわからないものがあるん
いうふうに思いますん
こんぺいとう速で貼って今日は私がどうして
蛇光院大附中これから衛生に関わるようになったのか
私たちは今て作ってるわけですけども
こんな遠征が一体どんなふうに使われていくんだろうか
そういったことをお話にしていきたいとおもいます
私は宇宙と出会ったのは大学ノウハウ付 fa のまあ勧誘ですん
その大学の編成は秒開きが輝かせながら今研究室学生の手の国の人口挨拶を持ってるん
だよ
犬たちもぜひ手伝ってほしい
というわけ
ああああああ
けんこう園
想定がいいんですよね
でまぁ一方デー
あの子ならほかの人ができないことができるかもしれない
と思ったんん
もともとやっぱり自分にしかできないことをやりたいと思っていた私にとって
まあ非常に今人生のカールミシンだったらも今からすれば思います
で銀行へ天日で喜んで調べるわけですよ
手間ワクワクドキドキしながら開発現場に行っ
平成を見たときにこれがフラップ召喚た時に私はビックリでしたおしまい
ん
皆さんちょっと上の部分で皆さんのも人口約縁起物を想像してみてください
ですかじゃああー見せしますこれ
うん
場になるよ
突然様は例えば大きな異性とか想像してきてこれがエサだと言われる理由
ん
出前でだかデータだっていうんですから待とうぜ打ち上げて貯まるわけでそれがこれ編
a day
持ってしまっていますけれどもまあ
ロケットらぼん
いうことあるねえ
猫の中約款が入ってるわけ
8中田普通にサッカーが3つ入ってますね
いる
ん
蓋をしてで縦に運ぶ
えっ何がなん
ということで残念なならばのペットは宇宙まではいけません
ビジョン小さいのでこれが4車で浮き上がります
でこの度4級を淘汰すると中の時間が放出されて
マックイラクしてはいけませんので
熱燗にはパラシュート買っていくん
演奏するとだいたい15分から20分かけて夢に降りてくるわけですけども
その間にさまざまな実験をくる
うーんまたがん
まあ今バーと話しましたけども秋考えてんじゃなかなかいいんじゃないんじゃないかな
と思います
japan の中身を
お見せしたいと思うんですけども
これがその空き缶の中なんですね
秋田の中身にはコンピューターアンテナ
それからバッテリー
送信機ですね阿蘇インターものが所狭しと詰め込まれているわけです
うわぁこれらの構成部品には全部人超えた中に入っているんですね
ですので空き缶であってもまあ市場人超えてやる
呼べるのではないかと考えていますそれで我々は我々はこれをやっ変え不安だと思う
いう名前で呼んでいます
で当然ながらこういうサーチを作った学生は衛星なんてどんなものがば part 作る
わけですね
なので当然ながらこういったものを初めて食ったところですね失敗しちゃうよね
このいざに増えてしまってますけども解説ブレーキあたらなかったというのは
いくことが2個そんな気じゃないんだよねたくさん失敗しません
えっここで重要な点がありません
本物得てっていうのは宇宙で打ってしまったら
そういう不安もなさないですよね壊れてしまったら
書いてありますね当然ながら日報この観察特有のコード4秒までしか来ませんから後で
回収できるわけです
ん
ソロするともし保証してしまっても何が悪かったのかっていうのを解析してですね
次に活かすことができるわけです
これを繰り返すことに失敗して次は同じミスを犯さないよねこれを繰り返すことによっ
て私たちの衛星開発の技術レベルな
少しずつ上がっていった
この感覚というものをクンクンしてその時にやっぱり普及に行くものをつけてあげるよ
ね
頭にあったのがもうキューブ参加ということで
キューブだともどんなものだろうか
大から10ペンキリップを重さは2kg
皆さんの手のひらに乗るサイズの本当にキーパー読む
我々が作った時は世界さあ抄訳です
猫の計2棟をつくったのが東京大学とここ東京工業大学の勝手だからん
右のキューブサットが東工大の
9と1区のバー
はーいっ
ですか皮膚という名前が降りますねデザインで開発たらちょっとだけお見せしたいと
思いますん
これ
平成が埃に弱いということを聞いたことのある方いらっしゃるかどうかわかりません
けれども
まあここに弱いのでまあ部屋の一角をとか美乳で囲って中を
ね
で実は誇りの行き場の発生源は人間力ですのでこういった写真のようにですねクリーン
ウェアというものとで作業する理由
ね作業車も手の先にあるのは俺はさっきキューブたんですね
ここで前の指にいろんなものが悠々と埋め込まれているのがわかるかと思いますけれど
もこれも当然ながら母尊いないように光ってきた人が生かされているというわけ
であまりにも
平成が小さいのでなんと飛行機の波に乗ってしまう
極楽世界で初めての事例だと思います
これがですねキューブタント2つの音灯台トークのコーナーの give カットが
打ち上げ局前に立つやされたまひめ写真ですテーブルの上の空のが旧寒いですね
浮き上げ場所はが残念ながら日本ではなくロシアのプレゼンスフーチューぶ人
いうところから行いません
8直前には東京からだいたい15人くらいの学生が裸体者作業を行うために異次元
何年
6月半円に2つのキューブサットはぷチーク中に地球を離れて宇宙に向かう
私はちょうどこの時にロシアげいたんですね
人への状況をまあ日本にキャップで伝えるとインターネットの回線が取れちゃうぞ
相当細かったのであのキャットという非常にプリミティブな方法でデータを聞いてい
ました
この瞬間の気持ちがなかなか衛兵甲斐あったんですか分からないんだけれども
今回この2年間年かけて作ってきたものが今夢中に行こうとしている
ブーブー張ってきたんだからブーイング気持ちまあ here なかったっけ
ああああああ
でまっ当時思った言葉ですねまあ嫁王
違うは娘を嫁にある時ってこんな気持ちなのかなというふうに思った憶えがあります
て登場ですね学生なんかが作ったエッセイがうまく動くわけないじゃないか
a pro のへいへい開発者に言われましたん
思ったわけですね
まあやとしてはデモカー sat 以来3年間積み上げてきた技術
今密かなも自信があったわけです
研究数時間もシーンで詠唱にかけて育て育ててきた方人工衛星が今宇宙に行こうとして
いる
絶対成功するんだろう
ヒューマン熱い想いもまあ当然のがありました
でっ
これはパス名声は
大生するんですね
投稿内ではこれを祝おうということでなんと
垂れ幕が
登場しました
でプロ大遠征はですね携帯電話用のカメラモジュールを積んでいて
右中間取った美しい地球のよを送ってきてくれたんですね
人は小さいですけども当時の最先端の
a まあカメラというとまあ写メールとか言ってた時代ですからそれぐらいの性能だと
思っていただければ
声届いたというのは非常に画期的なことだと思います
で驚くべきことにこの a セットの未だに打ち上げてから10年たった今もちゃんと
動いてるんですね
でまぁもちろん学生ば運用してませんけども日本のアマチュア無線家の方々が趣味で
週末に更新を楽しんでくれているという状況です
さあこの後我々はまあ一個作ってあぁ満足したという理由には当然いかずですね
その後もたくさんの野生をつくっていくことになるわけです
で私は卒業すると非常に強く思ったことがあります
10年間育ててきたまあこの衛星技術をですね
やっぱり社会の役に立つものをしたい自分たちが作って楽しいっていうだけじゃなくて
やっぱりいろんな人にその恩恵をええ感じてもらいたいというふうに思ったわけです
でじゃどうするん
10年間せません8周りにですねじゃあこういった小型1を作っている会社があるか
どうか
っていうのを考えた時に当然ながらないわけですよね
でもあきらめずにないならもつくろっ
ということで最初にキューブサップを成功させた3人の仲間が集まって
会社を新しい会社をつくって
でそういったビジネス向けの衛星を作り始めますそれが2008年ですね
出た時は流れ
一緒に冷静を作る仲間を埋めました
成果もなく本当にまもなくですけども2期目のエッセイが
打ち上げられます平成は今6個でもロシアからあげるんですけども
ロシアで打ち上げを待っている状態です
でだいぶ大きくなりましたよね
一辺が60センチもさん60キロぐらいあります
これ超小型ていいかどうかっての議論がありますけれども我々はまあチョコが伝説呼ん
でいる
で大きくなったのでそれを伴って生の曲がっています
で望遠鏡が付いてましてこの度500キロの柱空間から地表を観測することができます
地上分解の6.7m 事情分解能というのは地上のものをいかに身を蹴られるかって
能力ですけども
6.7m のものが1ピクセルに入るという風に考えてください
バレエを見てもらった方が早いと思いますこんな感じで取れるシュミュレーション画像
ですけども
は都市部であれば a ビルやあるいは道路の渋滞状況がわかる
同地であれば畑へとが一枚一枚はっきりわかる
これぐらいないがあの60キロこの衛星から見れるということなんですね
でまぁこれは非常に画期的なことなんですけどもちょっとよく考えてください
ネット大きなやつでこれまでになさとか jaxa が作っている
大きな石を使えばもっと細く見えるわけですね
なぜわざわざ小さい性を作らないといけないのか
小さい星のメリットって何でしょう
シンプルで
安い早くできる
誰もが思いつくことだと思いますけれどもしかしこれだけでは単なる
大型野手の駅かターン安かろう悪かろう思っちゃうわけですね
でわれわれはこれを解決する手段を一つ見つけました
なんだと思いますか
要は大方異性と直接対決しなければいいわけですね
それがはずです
樹氷以上に細かく見られなくても衛星がたくさんあることによって世界中のいろいろな
地域をいっぺんに見ることができる
まあこういったメイトが当然出てくるわけです
地上分解能の勝負をあきらめて時間分解のつまり
観測頻度によって新しい価値をつくっていこうと
しているわけです
これまで2週間に1回しか見られなかったものが最終的には1日4回5回いられるよう
になります
いくつかメリットをご紹介しましょう例えば農業ですね汗ません
農具んですね平成活動は a まあこういった針鳥好きとか
a
そういうのを制作するために使われている精密農業を見ますけども使われるんですが
植物の成長スピードを考えるとやっぱり
丸藤にチッカーが発足したいですねそういった意味で衛生品頻度の高いかをセブって
いう意味がある
それから遠隔地のプラントあるは大規模校でいます
携帯の電話電波が飛んでいない発展途上国での大きなプロジェクトにあたっては宇宙
からの見守るということが重要な解決手段になり得ます
それから自分ない
まあ今でも地上の渋滞というのはまあいろいろ
センサーがあってもありますけれども
a 宇宙から見ると今日は広い範囲がいっぺんに見えるんですね
そうすると渋滞起こった原因が分かる
そうするとより効率的でインテリジェントなナビゲーションサービスを提供できるかも
しれないわけです
それから希少はどうでしょうこの絵は何が分かるかどうかちょっと難しいかもしれませ
んけども
まあコンフィ照明セットひまわりの皆さん思い浮かべると思うんですが
暇えっていうのは高度3万6000キロん
の静止軌道上にあります
一方我々の作る衛星っていうのは高度100キロ600キロ
すごく近いですよね地表にそうすることによって雲の種類あったり服もの高さであっ
たりということが手に取るようにわかります
でこの情報があれば今ではやはり右側が難しい
ええまあ局地的な豪雨ですとかあるいはトップ
まあそういったものは予測精度が上がるという風に考えています
それからちょっとこれが画像の話ではないですが皆さんの今の周りではですね色んな
モノがインターネットにつながっています
私はまクライベイビーと呼んでますけどこれは衛星にまでハマると思ってまして
ただそれが500キロ上空にあるわけですねそれからもう一個重要な点は
例えば砂漠にカメラがあっても今はそのネットワーク繋がりませんけども
衛星があることによって
地上地球単位で情報を収集することができるということなんですね
しかしこれを実現するためには今名車のあり方が180度変えないといけない
それはやっぱり大型伊勢ようにたくさんエイプ一部の人が高いお金を払っている世界
から
地球所のいろんな人が当たり前のように使えるような情報にしていく必要があるという
ことで
そのための支度金というものもおれオレすでに早くしています
あとはたくさん作っていくだけ
で皆さん2020年には東京オリンピックやってきます
我々の衛星コンステレーションを使ってパッとプロのどんどん変わっていく姿を捉え
ですねそれを記憶している
そういうことを考えています小さな伊勢大きな可能性にぜひご注